[Music]
you can bet on many things now legally
in a growing number of American states
in New Jersey they have a prop bet as to
who the first pick in the draft will be
and the two favorites are calimary and
Nick Bosa both at plus 110 that means to
be about a hundred you win a hundred and
ten dollars Boesel was the favorite but
early money came in on Murray and the
line has shifted to make them Co
favorites next Quentin Williams the
Alabama defensive tackle 300-plus pounds
who ran a 4 8 3 second 40-yard dash
he is plus 450 Ohio State quarterback
Dwayne Haskins is 14 to 1 I would not
make that bet he was 2/10 of a second
slower than Quinn and Williams in the 40
not that the 40 really matters for
quarterbacks Tom Brady ran a 5 to 8 look
I like that Nick mosa came out and said
that the Cardinals are making a mistake
if if they pass on me I and I would like
to see the 49ers take Nick post at
number 2 so the Cardinals have to face
him twice a year I think that just makes
for a good storyline and it makes a
rivalry that currently is bla into
something that would be intriguing but
you know look quarterback is it's easier
to assess that you got a good
quarterback than it is to assess it you
got a good pass rusher what's that guys
Reggie White
right he's not going to generate the
kind of numbers that will get people to
say oh now I know why you took him first
overall yeah you're exactly right I mean
look at look at a guy we talked about
earlier today right Jadeveon Clowney I
think most people go oh well look at his
sack you know stats look at his sacks
you know the production's not there and
I know you've heard this from me a lot
but he is one of those guys that the
stats just don't tell the story but
either the way there is that perception
out there that he didn't live up to the
number one pick billing and I get that
and I know what people are expecting is
your number one pick defensive end
they want to see double-digit sacks
every year and all of that but man there
is more to more to football than just
sacks they're Debian clown he's
phenomenal because he messes up so many
plays all the time
Bosa I mean going into the combine and
leading up to that everyone had him
pegged as the number one pick in the
draft I think it just speaks to as
people are just continuing to watch
Kyler Murray in the NFL and you know
coaches are just
iving in the film they're seeing it
you're seeing the tide turn and people
realizing whoa wait this Cuyler Murray
is not just some guy that runs around
and plays backyard football everything
else checks the box too and like we
talked about last week it's just a size
that's the only thing that there's an
issue with everything else is just
phenomenal and it's it's gonna be a
great discussing discussion and debate
between the two it is amazing that last
year Baker Mayfield first emerged as the
guy who would go number one overall just
like five days before the draft or even
less than that yeah and now Murray's
already in that discussion I really do
think Mayfield's performance last year
in Cleveland has gone a long way to
legitimizing and to eliminating this
idea that there is a minimum height
requirement on being an NFL quarterback
definitely I think you know I think Drew
Brees kind of like you know got the
water warm to where everyone's like okay
ok smaller quarterbacks can work and
then we got Russell Wilson and it was ok
see there look at Russell Wilson but
he's just a you know once in awhile type
thing
and now we see a Baker Mayfield come in
who's not as athletic as a Russell
Wilson where I think everyone that was
the final question ok yay yeah he's not
real big but he can't run like Russell
Wilson so how is that gonna work well
you know how it worked he danced around
the pocket and he can still see through
lanes and make unbelievable throws that
way it doesn't matter he's used to
playing at 6-foot and has had enough
reps that it doesn't affect him and then
here we are with Kyle Emery so I think
he got take about yeah Baker Mayfield
setting this up
if he doesn't knock it out of the park
last year I don't think there's any way
we're talking about Kyle Emery as a top
five pick maybe a top 15 or 20 but not
top 5 and think about that evolution
drew Brees was not a first-round pick
back in 2001 that was the year that Mike
Vick was number one overall and the
Chargers actually traded out of that
spot got LaDainian Tomlinson and picked
up Drew Brees in the second round of the
draft and I look at Russell Wilson
seventy fifth overall in 2012 taken
behind Andrew Luck rg3 Ryan Tannehill
Brandon Weeden and Brock Osweiler and
three spots after the Jaguars took
punter Brian anger so I think what
Wilson has done what Brees has done and
what Mayfield did last year is the first
overall pick that that just
sit off the table if you can play that's
all that matters you don't have to be
six-two six-three six-four if you can be
a guy who gets it done like Murray is
fine and they'll make it work and I
think that makes it even more likely I'd
say between him and Bosa
I just think it's gonna be Murray
whether it's the Cardinals or whether
they trade out of that spot
somebody's gonna be the one that want to
be the team that says we got Kyler
Murray in the event that he is the next
in this line of Patrick mahomes deshaun
Watson Baker Mayfield the next big thing
who's gonna be around for 15 years it
certainly seems like it's shaking out
that way and the other thing that I
think the hurts Nick Bosa in this
conversation is the crop of defensive
pass rushers that are in the draft so
teams might go oh I want him but I'll
trade back and get a play this may be
just slightly less
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports